our channel the foundation of our
channel is entrepreneurship capitalism
business owners you know being unplugged
and doing things on your own terms
rather than kind of going with the
system and obviously your channel
entrepreneurs and cars there's a lot of
uh simpatico going on there I kind of
you know I would say 90 of our audience
are young men 20s 30s what have you I'm
in my early 40s I kind of look at myself
as like a big brother to some of these
guys right like 10 years younger than me
are you late 40s early 50s how old are
you right now yeah we can say late 40s
or do you early 50s okay I've I've
gotten to the point where I realize it's
better to keep information about me as
private as possible so I don't enjoy
stuff like that so where I understand
that where I'm gonna go with this is I
kind of look at you as like as an uncle
right whereas more I'm more of a big
brother you're more of an uncle but uh
the point is
I'm I'm someone who looks at you as like
I want to get to where Richard is at and
there's young guys that look at me as
like I want to get to where it's Adam's
at there's levels to this so where I
want to kind of go here is real quickly
is uh goals whether it's
um Financial dating and life goals real
quick in your opinion what goals should
a man reach by age 30 by age 40 and by
age 50. so let's start with the first
one a guy in their 20s where should they
try to reach goals uh Financial dating
and life goals by age 30 then we'll go
down the line
um so as far so as far as life goals I
mean you got to get your health sorted
out I mean if you can't if you can't
live in a healthy masculine strong body
you're not going to fix your mind
there's there's too many guys walking
around carrying way too much weight
they're either obese or morbidly obese
there's there's somewhere on the scale
where they just are not fit I mean if
you get out of the shower and you look
down and you can't see your Johnson you
got weight to lose and there's a lot of
dudes in their 20s that need to fix that
first so that would be the number one
thing that I would say is get your
health right and that you have no excuse
for it in your 20s literally in your 20s
um most guys even when I was growing up
are Fitness regime you know included
eating a bag of Doritos smoking a joint
pounding back a protein shake and going
to the gym there's no reason why you
cannot get fit in your 20s your
metabolism can adapt to pretty much
anything that you eat you should be able
to get fit as far as money goes I tell
guys and I get heat for this I tell guys
you should aim to be a millionaire by
the time you're 30 I'm be like having a
million dollars sounds like money to
some people or sounds like a lot of
money to some people but I really don't
think they understand or even comprehend
how little money a million dollars is in
today's world and we'll even I mean if
you're a 20 year old that's aiming to be
a millionaire by the time you're 30
that's going to be even less significant
in 10 years by the time you're 30. right
so I tell guys become a millionaire by
the time you're 30. at the very least
hit it by the time you're 40. by the
time you're 50 you should be a
multi-millionaire right so there's work
to do there
um so we had health goals we had
financial goals what was the other one
dating relationship goals by age 30.
yeah so
um I subscribe to the notion that men
really shouldn't spend a lot of time in
long-term committed relationships in
their 20s they should figure out what
women are all about date
um probably not invite a woman into
their life on a permanent basis
definitely don't live with a woman
um in your 20s and then by the time
you're in your 30s then you can start
asking yourself questions like do I want
to have kids or I want to raise a family
do I want to do this Mary do I not want
to get married do I want to do this
North America is there somewhere else
that I might want to do this is sort of
weigh out the risk factors and then sort
of start planning for that
ideally I mean you know if you want to
have kids I would say aim for mid 30s
likely I mean if you leave it too late
you're going to be an old father and
you're going to have pretty low energy
so that's something that you sort of
have to contemplate you know as far as
your dating goals some guys can go well
into the 30s and 40s and do whatever
they want you know they'll just date a
bunch of women spin some plates uh
they'll be monogamous they'll be
non-monogamous you can do whatever you
want in the world you know the whole
point of unplugging from society's lies
is to pick a path follow it and do what
serves you yeah the the last part you
said definitely resonated with this 42
year old over here who's been living in
South Beach for most of his life
spinning plates making money having fun
but you know oftentimes it's the people
closest to you especially in your 30s
when you hit late 30s the mother the
grandmother the Father the cousin the
uncle when are you going to get married
Adam weakness is like you have no idea
and have a family exactly it's like you
guys all look miserable out there you're
trying to tell me bring me into misery
as they say misery loves company Richard
I'm going to give you slight agreement
and slight pushback on something that
you just said so you said obviously in
your 20s get in shape you know I was
that dude at like 27 28 that was a
little out of weight and this is the
problem with a lot of people is you make
excuses I would say things like I don't
trust someone who's 30 and has abs what
the hell kind of time do you have you
have abs at age 30. it's like yeah now
I'm 42 and I'm working on get like I
have abs now because it's just an excuse
It's like well I'm working I'm too busy
for abs it's an excuse so I I fully
agree with you that in your 20s health
is wealth for sure and then as far as
like getting married unless you're the
anomaly exception to the rule don't even
think about getting married by age 30.
you might have a girlfriend that's cool
I get it you kind of got to understand
women where I kind of want to give you a
little bit of like I don't know how
realistic is it for someone by age 30 to
become a millionaire meaning that should
be a goal hell yeah I became a
millionaire at age 35 and it took me a
lot of time a lot of effort but keep in
mind in my early 20s I was bullshitting
wasting a lot of time
so we're in a full agreement that that
should be a goal I guess my question is
how realistic is it for a young man to
become a millionaire by age 30 today
I think it's entirely realistic but why
can't you pick bigger goals that's the
problem is you know you're thinking
anyway so why not think bigger like why
are people setting small goals from
themselves like I want to be worth a
hundred thousand dollars by the time
they're 30. a million dollars is not
that much money it's not that hard to
make right you're not going to make it
if you're working at the local grocery
store stocking shelves uh now if you're
clever and you go about your life in
such a way where you're not goofing off
with your late teens in your early 20s
and you sort of set the groundwork for
your life you can go out there and build
a business and make great money I know
lots of 30 year olds that are
millionaires
this mindset you have is it's like you
struck me as a type of dude that's like
yeah thanks for the excuses buddy get to
work that that's the kind of guy that
that you remind me of uh did you is that
something that you've always had or is
that something that you needed to learn
and then follow-up is at what age did
you become a millionaire
that's a great question so I didn't hit
it at 30. I probably hit it around 33 34
or so
um so like when you hold yourself to
higher standards you will get greater
results like um I don't I don't follow
the whole Tony Robbins sort of thing but
one of the things that he said that's
always resonated with me is if you want
to get better results out of life hold
yourself to higher standards hold the
people around you to Greater standards
and you know if you set the bar in the
sand here then you're probably going to
hit something around here but if you set
the bar in the sand up over here you're
going to do a lot better and have a
better chance of getting to that so
holding yourself to higher standards is
not that complicated of a thing to do
you just have to go and do it it's like
when I tell guys like why do you
surround yourself with losers if you
surround yourself with five fat broke
dumb people that are doing nothing with
their lives you're going to be the six
yeah unplugged from that mess of losers
that you hang out with and surround
yourself with better people put yourself
in better rooms I fully agree with you
and at two points that I'll that I'll
that I'll give you credit on which I
fully agree with Richard it's that your
network is your net worth who you're
surrounding yourself with and then
setting loftier goals so one of the best
things that that that has happened in my
life is 10 years ago I met Patrick Bett
David my CEO business partner friend
Mentor working out in the gym ironically
at a financial conference uh and
Natalia's family has known Pat for 10
years I I think very highly of her
family she could speak to that two
things with that he says you should set
lofty goals and you should reach 80
percent of them why 80 because if you
reach a hundred percent of them your
goals weren't lofty enough you should
kind of get crazy and be like I agree
holy [__] I can't believe I reached that
but if you reached 100 it's like well
maybe your goals weren't uh crazy enough
right and then number two uh you know we
had this conversation with the comedian
Brian Callan yesterday uh who's I'm a
big fan of great guy
um he's hilarious he said
um
you know Pat says you know you talk
about your you know you are you are the
accumulation of there are the uh the of
The Five People You surround yourself
with right and Pat goes yeah is it
really five or is it one meaning of the
five is there one who really their words
and their actions carry the most weight
and for me that's Pat right like I have
a network of five people but I'm so
lucky to have a guy like Pat in my life
just like I'm sure there's a lot of
young men that are counting Their
Blessings they have Richard Cooper in
their life so is it really five or is it
one that kind of has the the biggest
influence over you yeah I think when
you're younger you probably spend time
with different size groups but again I
mean the person you spend the most time
with you will probably become something
like carbon copy of what they're like or
you take yourself and their so them you
kind of average you know yourselves out
that's where you're gonna end up that's
why it's incredibly important to be
Discerning in your taste with friends
that you surround yourself with women
that you decide invite into your life
it's really important and it's something
that a lot of guys get wrong they just
you know when it comes to women it's the
first girl that touches her pee pee oh
she touches my peepee I'm gonna go get
married to her now they have no
experience and they have no idea what
they're doing right
um You have to be Discerning in your
test taste and nobody tells kids this
this isn't something that they educate
kids with in school most parents don't
really do it because they never really
did it themselves that's where we're at
today yeah of course they they I wish
they had a class what should you do with
the first girl that touches your people
marriage no do not do that all right
wouldn't that be great that's great
advice for young men by the age of 30. I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out